hey everyone it's your buddy Josh look
you all have been asking I listened and
here it is this is a compilation of
three of my favorite weird [__] stories
there's one about my wife there is one
about maybe the most scared I've ever
been in my life and one about one of the
highest moments in my life honestly was
not that easy to pick just three but I
think I picked the three best but let's
start with an unfortunate morning this
will give you a window into the world of
what my wife has to deal with on a daily
basis enjoy we already have three kids
um and but she was talking to me about
have another kid and I was like that
that sounds pretty [__] dumb
um we have old kids like I'm not
reenlisting you don't go back in for
another 18 that's [__] dumb that's
really dumb you know what I mean like if
I I wouldn't know what to do with a
[__] baby right
now here's what I here's my here's my
theory on babies when you have babies
are like
farts because you love your
[Music]
own but if you had to sit in a car with
somebody else's with the windows rolled
up you'd be like I'mma [__] kill this
[__] right
now so I I but I told her I was like
yeah you want to have a a a a you want
to have another kid and she was like
yeah she was but I need you to go to the
uh Fertility clinic cuz I smoke a lot of
weed and she was like you know weed is
really bad for your semen which made me
laugh when she told me cuz I was I was
pretty [__] high and
uh I was just picturing my sperm
swimming around inside of her like Chin
chong like oh no I'm not going to swim
up there man I'm G to hang down here on
the walls
like I was like yeah I'll go has anybody
in here been to her Fertility clinic
just me and my old balls okay here we
go well I'll tell you something right
now there are some awkward situations
you find yourself in I've never found
myself in a more awkward situation than
being in the lobby at the jerk off
doctor's
office because look you're sitting in a
lobby with seven dudes all strangers but
everybody knows that everybody's just
waiting to go jerk off it's bizarre
there's no eye contact some dude tried
to shake my hand and I was like [__] you
we are not shaking hand and look there
are times in my life where it's nice to
be recognized and there are some places
where I don't want to be recognized like
the jerk off doctor's office and and let
me tell you why the jerk off doctor's
office is so weird in the lobby look
it's not a secret we all know we all
masturbate that's not a secret but you
but you don't call your
shot you don't announce it to other
people do you know what I mean it's not
like the game Clue where you're like
it's Josh in the living room with a sock
do you know what I mean
like we've got a little
more we got a little more decorum than
that you know what I
mean so I'm trying not to make eye
contact and I can just feel this dude
staring at me
just I turn to him and he goes I know
you and I said no you
don't and he goes no no no no I know you
what's your name again and just then
from be the counter the woman she said
uh you Mr comedian you want to come on
up here and fill out your paperwork and
I was like okay so I walk up there now I
know none of you have ever been to a
fertility clinic but let me tell you
there are two questions on the paperwork
that I would I that stumped me question
number one how do you plan on making
your deposit
today
masturbation or other and I was like
well I got a [__] question right now
I said what's other and she goes do you
plan on masturbating I go well it kind
of depends on what other is doesn't
it because if you're sending in nurse
other I'll check that box right
now she was like I can't tell you what
it is like are you telling me there's a
there's a there's an alternative to
masturbation that's so good you haven't
even [__] named it
yet you're not going to tell us what it
is she goes I really can't I'm like oh
okay she goes maybe I can tell you later
I go okay the next question that stumped
me stumped me how much do you plan on
depositing
today I don't know all I don't jerk off
in a measuring cup at my
house all I'm not all of it I'm not
going to be in the other room like this
[Applause]
yeah I don't jerk I don't jerk on I'm
like I got a teaspoon and a half today I
have [__] all of it I don't need a
doggy bag all of it you know what I mean
whatever she was like go sit down I'm
like [__]
fine I walk into the lobby and the dude
was like hey man I go
no couple minutes later she goes it's
your turn I go okay I go into the room
and I walk into this room and right away
guys I know oh there's no way I can
masturbate n
it was a testament that room was a
testament to how gross dudes are let me
tell you how gross dudes are the couch
that I was supposed to sit on covered in
plastic which means they had washed it
so many times that the dude was like you
just got to [__] wrap that
up the the remote control that I was
supposed to hold covered in plastic I'm
going to go one step further on how
gross dudes are the front of the
television was covered in plastic that
means some dude jerked off on the TV he
was like I don't want kids sorry about
[Music]
[Applause]
that so sorry about I was aiming at you
though so you know
okay so I was like man I I I uh I don't
want to touch anything in here but I
knew how important it was to my wife so
I was like okay and then I remembered
her telling me that when she's in a
place in a bathroom that's dirty that
she doesn't want to sit on the toilet
she hovers right you all hover over the
seat so I was like oh I'll just I'll
hover
jerk so I get to right here and I'm I'm
masturbating and I'm about 20 seconds in
and I was like my [__] quads are
burning right I was sweating profusely
I'm like [__] CrossFit this is the best
workout I've ever had in my entire life
I'm going to I'm going to [__] open
up a hover jerk studio and close down
CrossFit like right
now I'm sweating I'm cramping cramping
and I'm like I need some water right so
I start to walk out to the front and I'm
sweating guys I'm breathing heavy I'm
cramping so I'm limping sweat dripping
off my face and I'm walking out to the
front like some weird Survivor I'm
like and the woman was
like are you okay and I said
uh I think I'm going to need to know
what other
is she said I can't tell you that but I
get you water I go okay I drink the
water I go back in the room I finish up
I come out I go to fill up my paperwork
so I can get out of there and the dude
who recognizes me in the lobby comes up
and he stands this far away from me and
he goes I know who you
are Mr
comedian and I go oh well nice to meet
you man he goes yeah he goes wait till I
tell my wife you were here I go what and
he goes yeah yeah I go do you feel like
you really need to do that and he was
like yeah she's a big fan man big fan I
just go to tell her and I go okay that's
fine and he goes yeah and then he
goes can you fill this out for her I go
sure and he goes can you sign it make it
funny some about being in the jerk off
doctor's office I'm
like so I'm starting to fill it out and
he looks at me and he goes
goes he
goes I saw you walk out of there all
sweaty he goes what was happening in
there and I said you should definitely
check
other and he goes oh okay and then he
goes to me he goes wait I I can't wait
to tweet about this I go no dude you
can't can't tweet about it and he goes
what not I go because we live in a
country of stories you don't remember
facts you remember stories when you
think of Charlie Sheen you don't think
of platoon Ferris beeler's day off dudes
had a bunch of hits you know what you
think of hookers and crack because we
remember stories and I don't want to be
sweaty jerkoff guy for the rest of my
[__] life do you know what I mean so
I go dude don't tweet he goes I'm gonna
have to tweet man I'm so sorry but I'm
GNA get so many followers when I tell
people you were here and I was like [__]
I'm about to sign my name and he goes oh
wait till I tell tell everybody that I
met Dane Cook and I was like
[Music]
[Applause]
Dane walked out of there feeling pretty
[__] good about myself I'm not going
to lie to look for you guys watching
don't judge me I don't get 10 minutes by
myself very often everybody hey I know
you're judging me I know you are if you
know you got 15 20 minutes by yourself
none of your no kids in the house no
wife that's when it happens and it's
it's the best this next clip is easily
the most scared I've ever been in my
life for a prolonged period of time now
I've had people jump out of bushes and
scare me where I thought my insides were
going to drop out of my pee hole this
was just one long butt clench you know
what I
mean I hope you can hear it and feel it
and see it on my face I'm I sweat when I
tell the story the most scared I've ever
been enjoy that I'm in New Zealand my
biggest fear for your Heights they have
one of those giant space needles and I
was like I'm going to jump off that
needle and my buddy Heath who was
showing me around I go Heath I'm jumping
off that needle he was like I'll go with
you [__] great so we go down there I
walk into the office and I ask the woman
I go what's the deal she goes okay 700
feet straight up 16sec fall and then
it's over I was like it's
over she said the jump is over I go
that's what that's what you should say
you should say the jump is over
I just [__] a little bit for no reason
you know what I
mean I said what what's the deal I'd
like to see someone jump when when's
that going to happen she said half hour
do you want to wait scared of heights
people you know what we're not doing
standing next to that [__] needle for
30 minutes no way because then I'm never
going to jump right I just need to it
needs to be a last second I go under I
go no no I'll come back and she said
okay but I left dude with every
intention of never coming back
but the truth of the matter is the only
reason I didn't just flat out not go
back I didn't want to come up with the
reason not to jump because I felt like
that would make me a [__] but if
somebody else came up with the idea I
could just go yeah you're probably right
I probably shouldn't jump right and
who's going to give me that idea my wife
I call her on the phone I go hey babe
she goes hey she said you need that
needle I said I am and before I could
say anything else she said hey please
don't puss out
and I said what she goes I know you're
calling me so I'll give you a reason not
to jump I'm I'm not going to do that she
said I know you and I know the only way
you get disappointed in yourself and
this is true is when you don't try when
you feel like you quit and you hold on
to that [__] for a long time she said I
don't want that to happen to you I don't
want you to hang on to this for months
so please just jump and I told her I go
babe thank you very much it's cool to be
married to somebody who knows me so well
well so I appreciate you looking out for
me and she said I I didn't tell you that
for
you I said what she goes you know when
you hang on to it you know what you do
talk about it all the
time she goes I don't want to hear you
for the next three months I should have
jumped you know I should have jumped I
should have jumped you know I should
have
jumped she said so just jump I go okay
and I hang up the phone and guys here's
how you know I'm scared
when when you see me super confident
extra bravado I'm frightened that's how
like I that's what my Alter Ego is from
my fear this is how scared I was this is
how much bravado I had when I hung up
the phone I turned to my friend heat and
I think I said something like
hey let's go [__] that needle in the
ass scared right but I was full of Rado
I go hey you want to [__] hey he you
want to fke
your and I hope I wasn't doing
this I go hey he you w't [__] jump
with me and he was
like
no I said why not he goes well for 16
seconds your body's going to feel like
it's dying right I said yeah he goes
yeah that sounds
terrible I don't want to do that he said
but I'll be sitting right there drinking
a beer smoking a joint waiting for you I
said okay
so I start to walk under the needle and
here's what I decide [__] the bra what I
decided in that moment was bravado was
me pretending to be somebody else and in
order for me to conquer this fear I want
to do it as me so I'm just going to
embrace this fear and see what happens
you know and as soon as I let go of the
bravado one thing I did learn about
myself is when I'm super scared guys my
lower body sweats a
lot a lot like a lot a lot right and so
I was like this is really weird feeling
you know but I but it actually felt good
I felt alive like present I felt there
and I was like [__] it and nobody knows
me in New Zealand I'll be just some
scared sweaty American they're going to
[__] love that right so fine just
Embrace this get up there conquer this
fear check this box and let's move on to
the next one no one knows you here you
should feel the most comfortable and I
just hand this dude my ticket and he
goes Josh
Wolf
and I looked at him and I go are you
sure and he said are you not
sure I said no I'm sure I said how do
you know me man he goes I was at the
Comedy Festival last night dude you're
the whole reason I went you're my
favorite comic I actually told everybody
here about you they're going to be so
psyched to meet you hold on one
second they make a semicircle around it
right now here's something you guys need
to know about me when I'm out in public
and I'm nervous and I don't know what to
do with my hands I do this on my
nipples so there's like 50 pictures of
me with these people like hey hey right
by the way side note side note probably
about three or four times a year I like
to go to the casinos take some mushrooms
and play the slots and and I'll tell you
why dude it's just the
simulation and not too long ago I was at
the Mohan sun which is a casino in
Connecticut and I was dude it was like
3:30 in the morning I was on mushrooms
when I'm on mushrooms I rub my nipples
too but not cuz I'm nervous just cuz it
[__] feels
good and so I was playing slots and I I
had like a $500 jackpot it was
[__] it's crazy you know and there
was a dude sitting next to me and I
didn't notice he was there and at one
point he looks at me and he goes hey and
I go
yeah and he goes he goes you you rub
your nipples for good
luck I mean what am I going to do say no
I I
I so I said yeah so me and this dude sat
next to each
other [__] rubbed our nipples like
hey at one point he was like it's not
working I'm like you got to rub them
harder he's
like
Okay so
they got making a little circle around
me and the people there know I'm a
comedian and they know I'm scared and
and they're making some jokes and I
don't mind that [__] you know and the
guy standing next to me goes all right
everybody enough with jokes Time to Say
Goodbye to Josh and I was
like
goodbye and he was like it's just a
saying I go [__] change
it and he puts me in my little on suit
in my onesie in my in my jumpsuit you
know
and uh and he put a harness on me real
loose and he puts me in this elevator
and he goes here you go this elevator is
going to take you 700t very slowly
straight to the top and the doors start
to shut and I go well aren't you getting
in he goes no just
[Laughter]
you elevator slowly Rises out of the
ground and as it does I look around and
I realize that this elevator is like 80%
glass I don't like the window open on
the [__] airplane
everybody but 80% glass you know what
that means right 20% wo so I'm not
kidding when it lifted out of the ground
I turned around and I [__] Blair
witched myself right against the wall I
just sat like
this I put my face against the wall I
closed my eyes and I was like this is it
right here I'm just riding this right
here and guys I was like 75% sure I was
going to die so I started talking to
people in the elevator who I wanted them
to hear from me one last time like I was
talking to my parents like Mom and Dad
thank you for always believing in me
Beth you're the best decision I ever
made and Jacob and Caitlyn and Trevor
you're my three heartbeats how do I know
I was screaming all those embarrassing
things well apparently they videotape
you
right when you walk in the elevator oh a
heads up with have been nice a sign
smile you're on camera something you
know what it is it's just a video of me
screaming the bitchiest [__] [__] any
human has ever
screamed I was screaming things like
guys I am on tape screaming this if it's
my time to go I'm ready but I'm not
ready
so we get to the top right I get to the
top and the door
opens and at the top were these two
young ladies and one was this
sarcastic biting say anything to your
face I don't give a [__] about your
feelings kind of
person and the other woman was exactly
the
same and I get up there right
and they started laying into me
immediately the door opens and I just
hear one of them go well come on out
here
princess and I walk up to the desk and
she hands me a clipboard and she goes
here you go I go what's this she goes I
need you to fill out this waiver I was
like wait
I said what's this waiver for and she
said you know what the waiver is
for and I was
like I said has anyone ever has anyone
ever had to use the waiver she said no I
said well that's good she said yeah but
their families did
what oh she was [__] with me so hard
I appreciated it but it was scary you
know she goes head out there they're
waiting for you and I walk out on the
deck now has anyone in ever been on top
of one of the needles the Strat in Vegas
or oh yeah did you did did anyone jump
no you jumped no I cried here you
go and did you skyd you skydived you
skydived yeah
nah I will tell you first of all guys
one thing that and anybody who's been on
top of these needles will tell you from
the ground looking up from the middle to
the edge looks huge when you get up
there it's 15 feet Max and at the Strat
just like all these places there's a
railing that you would hold and you walk
out to the edge which is what I'm sure
most normal people
do not your boy I was so scared guys I'm
15t from The Edge right when I get out
there I grab the railing with both hands
like
this I'm squeezing it white knuckling it
and I'm doing this with my feet this
feels safe this is
safe this feels safe this is safe this
feels safe how do I know I was saying
that oh they videotaped that part too
that's right I'm up there
[Laughter]
bug guys can I tell you something when I
finally got down to the ground the woman
who sold me the tickets she walks up to
me and she goes hey I go yeah she
goes you want that
video
I said yeah I want the video she goes
okay I hope you got a lot of room on
your
phone I go why she goes well what's the
longest video I've ever had to send
anybody I well how long's the average
video she goes 5 and a half minutes I go
well how long was I up there she said 37
minutes I said no way she goes yeah you
did safe safe for 17 minutes [__]
were they watching in real time how
humiliating I'm up
there they're in the office
[Laughter]
[Music]
like by the way
guys there are two groups that they L up
on that needle the jumping group the
other group they will let you do two
things they will let you walk along the
Edge by
yourself they say that cures your fear
of heights no it do hey [__] you that's
right you know what else they'll do dude
ready for this they'll attach a hook to
your onesie your jumpsuit and they will
hang you off the side so you're flat
looking down yo dude this guy walks up
to me he goes hey you want me to hang
off the
side and I was like do you want me to
[__] in your
mouth oh I will [__] up I will beat
gravity are you [__] kidding me right
now have you not [__]
[__] read the room bro no I do not
want you to hang me off the side of this
needle I'm just trying to keep my [__]
together right now you know what I
mean so the one the woman who was in
charge of you know getting me out there
she goes all right come on you got to
jump I've been up there for at least 17
minutes she was so sick me at this point
in time she goes come on you got to jump
off of here there's a line of people
waiting to get up here come on and I go
what happens if I don't jump she goes
what do you mean I go what happens if I
get in that elevator I ride it straight
down and just nobody ever knows she goes
well I mean if you did
that somebody might tweet about
it I said are you telling me that if I
don't jump off this needle you're going
to Tweet about it she goes no I wouldn't
I think Twitter's stupid I I really
think it's really dumb I said thank you
she said of course but she would her
friend was
like [__] I said can you help me I'm
just so scared she goes do you not will
you let me do my job she said do you
think you're the first grown man I've
had to talk off of this
needle you're not she goes let me ask
you a couple questions if you Googled us
I said of course she goes this is your
biggest fear I said it is she goes right
she said when you Googled us did you
find anyone ever died here I said no she
goes yeah has anyone ever been injured
here I said no she said that's right you
were quite literally scared of
nothing you're making things up to be
scared of instead of making things up
let me just give you the facts we've
been here for
years thousands and thousands and
thousands of people jump off here every
year and nobody ever even gets hurt we
change lives she goes let me tell you
something right now when you jump off of
here when you hit the ground I go hit
the ground
she was like you know what I'm talking
about I said I know you need to work on
your messaging that's I
know she said you're got to be a new
person you ready to be a new person and
I said uh
no that's your pep talk new person is
your halftime speech I go that's not
working for me what else you got she
goes okay I was just throwing that one
out and I got a couple more she said you
got kids I said yeah she goes your kids
know you're here I said yeah she goes
you want to disappoint your kids I said
I disappoint my kids all the time what
else go fish that [__] doesn't work on
me either what
up she said all right your kids know
you're scared I said of course and she
said do you want your kids to know that
it's okay to quit in life when they're
scared yes and I was
like I want to [__] push you off here
so bad
I was like no I don't want that she said
of course you don't she said get up
there when I get up to the edge and I
stand there guess what scared of heights
people it's not real until you hear your
very
first and my man that is followed
quickly by bo
bo
and she tightened up my harness
tight I'm not going to lie to you she
squished my left
nut and on a normal day I'd have told
her to list loosen that up but looking
700 feet straight
down I'll be old one nut Josh I don't
give a [__] it's better than being all
dead Josh that's what I'll tell you what
right now and what a great story to tell
your grandkids hey how's you lo how' you
lose your nut pop pop it exploded in
midair kids you
know so I'm standing there and something
happened to me that I'd only heard about
you guys heard the term Frozen with fear
I didn't think that was a real thing
until I couldn't move my [__]
body and I just had to tell her I said
listen I want to tell you something for
real no [__] around I have to do this
today this is why I'm here I cannot let
my fear beat me today of course I don't
want to disappoint my kids but the real
reason I'm here is she's right I grew up
with a lot of irrational fears and I
promised myself I would not hang those
hand those down to my kids and the only
way for me not to hand this down is to
do this today right now I have to show
them that there's nothing to be scared
of
but I can't
jump I
said you're going to have to push
me
and she looked at me and she
goes I
know I says you know she goes yeah we
watched your elevator right up I knew I
was
going were they're watching the
[Music]
[__] so like okay but by the way scared
H people guess what if they push you you
have to go off
backwards you have to see the push they
can't push you in the back it's against
the log so I turn around she starts to
walk at me like this and I was like are
you out of your [__] mind right now
you think I'm going to let you push me
like you're one of the Walking Dead get
your [__]
together yeah we're going to have to
plan this out look man I grew up with
three older brothers man a lot of us who
grow up the youngest of a big family
there's some PTSD that's involved with
that [__] one of my things is I was
scared multp times every day so that
means if you scare me to this day I'm
going to Jazz
it not only am I on a jazz hand it's
going to be followed by this
noise 100% of the time 100% of the time
right I already have [__] save save I
don't want to go with it you know what I
mean so don't you surprise me off this
[__] needle Now give me a good push I
go 1 2 3 push you ready she goes I'm
ready I go you ready she goes goes I'm
ready and I go one and right a was she
just goes W like
that she was so sick of me being up
there guys if she was allowed to scream
One you [__]
one you know I could tell she was
sicking me when she pushed me she didn't
look at me guys when you check the
camera she pushed me when she was
already walking back to the
office and in the camera after she
pushed me she gave me three of these
just like
that oh and on my phone I have a
16-second video
for so I get down to the
bot and uh the woman to S said the video
joke comes up and she goes hey hey CEO
wants to talk to you you got a minute
said yeah and he comes up to me he goes
hey man Tim hey I'm Josh and he said
first of
all how great was that I was like pretty
pretty [__]
terrible he was like but you're going to
do it again I go
no and he goes are you glad you did it I
said I'm so glad I did it and please
thank your staff they were very patient
with
me and I and I was about to walk away he
goes hey I just want you to know me
everybody in the office we really
enjoyed your video and I was like all
right
so I'm home a month later in the states
and my buddy from New Zealand Heath he
calls me and he goes hey man I go hey he
goes hey have
you have you been on that New Zealand
Jil
website and I said no and he goes you
should and I said what am I looking for
he goes you're looking for a
video I go where is it he goes it's
right on the front
page so I go to the front page and
there's a video of the CEO and the
beginning of the video he's just given
all the Vital Information about the 700
ft 16c fall where it is in downtown
Auckland what you can see when you're at
the top all the Vital Information and at
the very end he goes but most
importantly guys what you need to know
is here at New Zealand jump we've had
Zero fatalities here at New Zealand jump
we've had zero injuries what you need to
know is that New Zealand jump is 100%
And then it just cut to a video of me
going safe safe save safe safe safe SA
do you know I went back to New Zealand
to have Jacob jump and the guy walked up
to me and he was like you GNA jump again
and I was like you remember me he was
like we all remember you come on man
it's so weird that things that I'm
scared of and the things I'm not like I
would stand on stage naked in front of a
crowd that's not my that's not my hangup
but dude if you if I wouldn't jump off
this table I was sitting in front of if
I stood on to top of it I'd be like this
is kind of
high I'm sweat my hands are sweating
just thinking about it and The Last
Story guys look man you know me you know
I like to get high you know I like live
music I like to combine the two of them
but this time I may have gone a little
too far when somebody dared me to do
something this is a cautionary tale I
grew up poor and my dad was also pretty
cheap and because of that we I missed
out on a lot of experiences and I grew
up man I'm I'm I'm I'm bummed that I did
this but I grew up through my 20s and
30s like if I saw a steak on the menu
that was $24 and I saw a chicken that
was 17 I'd be like I should get the jig
even though I wanted the steak do you
know what I mean like I [__] hate
that my dad put that in my head so what
I've started to do is listen guys it's
important not to be willy-nilly with
your [__] money but if you got a 100
bucks and it's between sa 100 bucks
and going to a concert you've always
wanted to see go to that [__]
concert here's the deal a year from now
you're not going to have any idea where
that $100 went but you'll remember the
concert so make some [__] memories
while you can still make some memories
all
right so uh taking that into account
last September I got to see six bands in
one weekend all on the bucket list now I
spent more than I should have on this
concert it was it was a it was old cello
it was cachell for old people did
anybody go did you know what I'm talking
about it was the Stones The Who
McCartney Neil Young Roger Waters and
Bob Dylan all in the same weekend it was
amazing has anyone in here ever seen Bob
Dylan
before yeah he eats a bag of dicks that
[__] he's so bad did he play any
hits when you saw him not one [__]
hit dude doesn't play one hit are you
kidding me and I was so mad I'm like
play Tangled them blue and the guy next
to me was like yeah well it's Bob Dylan
he's earned the right to play what he
wants and I would agree with you if he's
playing in his own [__] living room
but he
wasn't there were 990,000 people there
who paid a lot of [__] money PT
Tangled Up and blue you piece of beef
jerky [__] you I will fight Bob Dylan
right now I'll tell you that right now
I'll fight that [__] I think I
got a shot at Bob Dylan I'd like to hit
him once just to hear him go I
just just a
quick
but on the way in right I told my
brothers I'm like hey guys I'm taking
mushrooms this
weekend and they were like which night I
said did you hear me this
[Music]
weekend and they were like why you going
to they go you you're going to do that
by yourself and I said no there there's
going to be 990,000 people
there and they were like you're not but
you don't know any of them I was like
well I'm I'm GNA
now okay so and by the way I did it out
of respect for the bands we were going
to see I felt like they would want me to
be [__] up right so B's got a
curiosity Round of Applause and I'm
assuming this will be a larger Round of
Applause and in most cities people who
have taken mushrooms
before guys I was in Huntsville Alabama
last weekend I asked that question and
one dude goes I got some on my salad
right now and I was
like and not what I'm talking about uh
so after Dylan I was like I'm taking the
mushrooms now I'm not I'm not I'm not
putting myself through another
disappointing show now at following
Dylan was the stones and I had never
seen the stones before and so uh and by
the way sitting next to me was this old
Hispanic couple and the dude had those
like the round tiny glasses and he had a
tiny ponytail you know one of these and
it was pulled tight so dude looked
surprised the whole show
[Music]
like
so and she scratched his back the entire
concert 2 and 1 half
hours so about 5 minutes before the
music starts I get my first little warm
hug and I'm
like I'm like this is about to be the
best night of my [__] life
right and so the guy next to me he turns
to me and he goes hey man and I go hey
and he goes what's your name I said Josh
and he said who do you think the best
rock band of all time is Josh and listen
guys I'm about to trip balls
right so the last thing I want to do is
have a conversation with the Mexican
John lennin you know what I mean like
I'm going Pasadena on that right [__]
now right so I just tell him what I
think is going to answer the stop most
conversation I said the Beatles and he
goes Whoa man it's the stones she and I
have seen the stones 66
[Music]
times and she said yeah and we refall in
love every show and I was like yeah I
was like that's sweet and I said that's
going to be
very cool for me to watch the stone for
the first time next to people who have
seen them 66 times and I'm going to
watch them refall in love right in front
of my face that's a belt to melt off my
[__] skull you know what I mean
like I felt like telling him I hope you
don't mind watching this concert next to
the Ghost Rider
because I'm not for sure what's going to
happen from here on out you
know
so I then start
in and I'm like oh my God
right I couldn't believe what was
happening not kidding 10 minutes in dude
turns to me and he goes hey man and I go
hey and he goes what's your name and I
was
[Music]
like
I said
Josh and he goes who do you think the
best rock and roll band of all time is
Josh and for a second I thought oh my
God these mushrooms are
amazing I was like this is the most
visceral Deja Vu I've ever had in my
entire life and honestly I'm going to
tell you I'm not going to lie to you for
a second I thought I can see the [__]
future
like I know how this conversation ends
oh I'm going to see this concert twice
[__]
yeah but we did the whole thing 66 times
re fall in
love not kidding no joke 12 minutes
later dude turns to me and he goes hey
man and I go don't you ask me that
[__] question again
dude and his wife goes to me you'll have
to excuse
him he's done a lot of drugs he doesn't
have any short-term memory and I was
like well no wonder you got to see the
stone 66 [__]
times and just so you know you don't
refall in love he thinks he bangs some
chick at the Stones concert every
weekend
like not as romantic as you think it is
Ma I'm just saying and then I will tell
you what the true privilege of my life
being there that weekend was watching
generation of people watch their Idols
for the last time guys so cool to see so
cool to see because they were partying
without inhibition look if we saw a bar
full of 65y old people upstairs getting
[__] up you'd be like go
home yeah as you'd make a group decision
you're like hey all of you you need to
go
right but this concert was for them it
was for them to come and relive a
snapshot of their life so they partied
without inhibition and it was amazing to
see and because of that there was a lot
of old white guy dance circles popping
up all over the
place if you haven't seen one of
those and when I say dance circle there
was a lot of Two Gun salutes you know a
lot and you could tell when they like
the song You Know Why the guns went up
in the air
right there was one guy near me doing a
lot of the
pencil and then near me also there was a
big guy doing kicks like this he had to
go like 240 big dude he's kicking he's
like yeah and I was like look at the big
guy go like he's killing it and then big
guy
just
collapses and I was like oh
no
he he [__] River danced himself to
death
[Laughter]
like and he's not moving and I'm like oh
this dude is in [__] trouble right so
they put they come in EMTs come they put
him on a stretcher wheel him out you
know and he's saying his eyes are closed
and one of his friends who's near me
leans over and goes the dude has to be
like mid 60s or something and he's over
him he goes hey man you're going to be
okay
and the guy just opens his eyes and he
goes yeah I'm just really
tired and his friend said what he goes
yeah I got tired from dancing around so
I laid down on the ground and then the
EMT said I can't lay here and I told him
I'm not [__] getting up I'm too tired
and the EMT said if you don't get up sir
we're going to have to will you out of
here and I said that actually sounds
kind of
[Music]
nice rock and
roll and this one [__] got a little
weird there was about a 280 290 lb dude
running around shirtless doing this to
people and I'm watching him and I'm
like oh I I really hope he doesn't come
over here you know
like so he comes over and his belly's
all sweaty so there's like tracers
flying off of his stomach
and his whole stomach's moving all at
once and I'm like I'm never looking
away I knew I was going to get [__]
trapped in that thing
right and then he said something to me
that I promise you has never been
uttered before in the history of human
beings he shakes his belly at me and he
looks at me and he goes hey I go what's
up he goes how many Knuckles deep you
think you can go on my belly button I go
what he goes how many Knuckles deep I go
no none Knuckles deep dude zero Knuckles
deep and he goes why not I was like well
why would I and he goes everybody's
doing it and I go who who the [__] is
doing that and he goes everybody now
look guys I'm
shrooming you know what I mean and and I
don't want to be the only guy who
doesn't finger [__] this dude's belly
button you know what I
mean I don't want to be Debbie Downer
you know what I mean I want to be part
of the
group so I go to him I go
uh what finger should I
use and he goes he goes I'd use the
index I go
okay guy's way to gets so much
worse
so I go to lube up my finger
right and he goes nah you won't need
Lube and I was
like well that's good news for
me and it just
[__] with room to spare right and I
look at him I go we got room to spare
big fella and he goes okay and I go to
pull my finger out and you know when you
put your finger in one of those Chinese
finger
locks and for whatever reason when you
try to pull it out it clamps down on it
I couldn't get my finger out of hisu
[__] belly button I went full Palm on
this dude's stomach
like cuz there's no way I'm going out
like that right I'm like and it just
popped out right as soon as it pops out
he looks at me and he goes we finally
found somebody to do
[Applause]
it I said I thought everybody was doing
that he goes who would do that I go
that's what I
[Music]
said
now let's get into a little truth time
you ready for a little truth time truth
truth time as a man as a man as a man I
had to fight every fiber in my body not
to smell that finger one [__]
time don't yuck me you hypocritical
[__] you graze your nuts the
first thing you do is smell them you got
a unicorn on your finger you're never
going to smell that [__]
again now listen I did it I didn't I
didn't I did not I did not do it I did
not do it I did I didn't I gave my
brother a dirty Sanchez and I was like
hey
dude what does that smell like he walked
around the whole day like this hey what
was what was that what was
[Music]
that because that's the type of [__]
I am I will say that is gross out is I
am sometimes thinking about it how many
people can say they stuck their finger
straight into the belly button of a
stranger and got it stuck in there but
wiping it under my brother's nose really
made it all better you know what I mean
if you see me out on these
streets ask me to smell my finger it
still has a little bit of
the on it I hope you guys enjoyed this
video I had so much fun putting it
together I'm going to put together a
bunch more of these compilations cuz a
lot of you have been asking for them so
here they come thank you all so much for
watching we'll see you out on the road
comedian Josh wolf.com
[Music]